sensibiliser et mobiliser le public à la
lutte contre la maltraitance et la
violence faite aux animaux c'est le
projet penser organisé et réalisé par
une quinzaine de jeunes de l'Académie
des Dallons du Bernica à Saint- Paul en
partenariat avec la SPA de la civice
elles ont donné rendez-vous aux amoureux
des animaux sur le front de mer de
Saint-Pierre la Société protectrice des
animaux du Sud a saisi cette opportunité
pour rappeler la souffrance dans son
certains chiens nous on essaie surtout
de mobiliser les gens à la maltraitance
parce qu'il y a énormément de
maltraitance sur notre île et
deuxièmement à l'abandon des bêtes dans
la nature quelles sont les sortes de
maltraitances qu'on rencontre alors là
des choses ça va du du chien qui n'a pas
d'abri qui en plein soleil ou sous la
pluie jusqu'à des maltraitances
physiques très graves dernièrement il y
avait les apparts sur les
chiens bah les chiens écrasés abandonnés
de la
route les chiens mal nourris
malheureusement l'abandon existe encore
la prolifération des chiens dans la
nature des chiens et des chats qui est
encore énorme donc on lutte aussi contre
la reproduction sauvage sensibiliser et
mobiliser le public à la lutte contre la
maltraitance et la violence faite aux
animaux c'est également le thème du
projet collectif de ces jeunes
pensionnaires de l'Académie des
Dallons donc il est né en conseil des
dalallons donc les volontaires ont fait
trois propositions de
cétait donc à la mijuin et donc on a
voté collectivement et c'est ce projet
là qui a été retenu l'opération
d'aujourd'hui donc c'est la
concrétisation du projet collectif de la
promotion 4 de l'Académie des alons des
jeunes femmes qui sont arriv il y a 3
mois maintenant et qui ont décidé de
monter une action de solidarité contre
la maltraitance animale on a tous décidé
de faire ce projet collectif sur la
maltraitance animale fait a récolté des
fonds pour pouvoir offrir le rappel de
vaccin aux gens qui veulent bien
aujourd'hui adopter un
chien les académiciennes ont mis un
point d'honneur à réussir leur projet on
accueille le public on expose les chiens
il y a un certain nombre de de stand
artistiques de brocantes de réalisation
qui ont été faites par les
académiciennes qui sont proposé au
public et l'objectif c'est aussi
d'expliquer le travail qu'elles font et
puis aussi de faire reconnaître leur
leur projet et le souci derrière c'est
de ben c'est c'est c'est c'est de
montrer de montrer que bah des jeunes en
action et ben ça peut
avoir ça peut leur permettre de grandir
je suis très très très
très stupéfait de voir tous ces jeunes
qui ont d'ex-même essayer de venir
cette association s'en sortir parce que
à un moment dans le vie peut-être qu'il
n'avent plus de repère et là il se
sontis en main
l'Académie nous apporté VI en
collectivité et en même temps ça nous a
permis de surpasser aussi no capacités
avec notre peur parce qu'on a fait des
randonnées tout ça rien que pour cette
image çaen valait la peine
bonjour